♪
(woman)
Since arriving at the San Diego
Supercomputer Center
on the UC San Diego campus
in the mid-1990's,
Beth Simon has made
computer science
and the teaching of computer
science her life's work.
But as a young girl
growing up in the Midwest,
she never imagined
her interest in computers
would take her to California.
(Beth)
I went to a small,
primarily undergraduate
institution in Ohio.
And really,
people from there
didn't tend to go to graduate
school in computer science.
But my professors
took an interest in me,
and they recommended
I apply
for a summer program
for undergraduates
that would give them
the chance to see
what graduate school
was like, so I applied.
I had no idea
where they would send me,
and interestingly enough,
they selected me and
assigned me to Fran Berman,
a professor
in the computer science
and engineering department.
Fran always worked in
high-performance computing.
Later she became director
of the Supercomputer Center.
That was my first introduction
to California and UCSD.
I always remember it
as a kid from the Midwest.
On the first day, I was in
graduate student housing--
these apartments
with window walls--
and I phoned my mother
and said,
"A guy walked by with
a surfboard on his head!
I'm in California!"
Once I came here,
it was too great to leave,
and that's what got me to
come here for graduate school.
So I know that females today
only are awarded 18%
of the Bachelor of Science
degrees in computer science.
That number has not changed.
It's gone down a little
the last couple decades.
What was that like for you?
My father was
a computer scientist.
When he got his degree,
you couldn't get a degree
in computer science yet.
But he got a master's degree
in computer science.
He encouraged me
to play around with computers
and give this a try.
As an undergrad,
I also majored in Spanish,
in case this computing thing
didn't work out.
But it's something that's been
part of my life going forward.
Even fewer women get PhDs
in computer science.
You really are very aware
that you're in a room,
one of the only women
in the room.
I've taught classes
as the only woman in the room
as the professor.
That makes you
an important role model today.
I also know that you have had
a passion for teaching,
I think, your entire career.
Mm-hmm.
You also are very curious
about how students learn.
You have a unique
teaching style.
You flip your classrooms,
you use a lot
of peer instruction,
so what does this mean
for your students?
Well, it really means that
they can have a very special,
very personal
learning experience,
even in a large classroom.
This is where my passion
for teaching came from.
I went to this
small university,
where class sizes
were capped at 20.
I'd always learned
in that environment.
Here I come
to graduate school at UCSD.
I sat in on some
undergraduate courses
with hundreds of people,
and I thought, "My gosh.
This is an awful experience
that they're having."
I also knew, because I had been
a graduate student at UCSD,
that most PhDs
in computer science
got no training whatsoever
in teaching--
not even
a T.A. training course.
We've since changed that.
But it is common that PhDs,
in general,
would not really get much,
if any,
training whatsoever in both
the practicalities of teaching,
let alone in the theories
of how people learn.
And so really it's one of
the most challenging things
because two things
come into play.
PhD's, or professors,
know what it's like
to be an expert
in a field.
They know it takes time
and effort and practice
and feedback to become
an expert in their field.
They also know they're supposed
to be experts at teaching,
just because that's what
professors are and do,
but know they've had
none of those four things
in preparation to teach.
They feel uncomfortable because
they know the meaning of expert,
but they know this isn't
something they necessarily have.
The other thing is,
especially for scientists,
we're trained to use data,
to look at data and use that
to reflect and improve,
whether we're optimizing
compilers and architectures,
as I did here
at the Supercomputer Center,
or whether you optimize
your teaching.
But there's
so little data available
when you are
teaching students.
How do you know how much they
learned from your lecture?
How do you know
if they're confused,
especially in
really large classrooms?
It's a pretty brave student
that would raise their hand
and say they're confused.
Then how do you
get feedback?
One way is through
this approach
that I use with
my flipped classroom.
I use an approach called
peer instruction.
The general view is
that students can learn
the basic stuff people
lecture about in the classroom
on their own.
They can read a book
or watch a video lecture.
But you really want to take
advantage of the time
that students are with you,
the expert,
to enable them to go deep
and get feedback from you,
which also allows you
to get feedback from them
about what they understand
or don't understand.
In a class that I teach
for an hour and 20 minutes,
students will spend about 45
minutes talking to each other
or talking to me
at the front of the classroom.
I'm not standing there
talking most of the time.
This contributes to
an incredible difference
in the classroom experience.
Students know they're
supposed to come to class
and engage with each other,
to talk
and figure something out.
And I do this by giving them
challenging questions,
which are
multiple-choice questions.
They vote on them using
this device called a clicker.
And the great thing
about using this technology
and asking people to try
a question and vote on it
is that it causes people's
brains to actively engage.
They have to commit to some
answer and think about it.
I get, immediately in the
class, the results of that poll
and see how students are doing.
You might think it just sounds
awful in the inverted classroom.
"What? She's going
to quiz me every time?"
It's not the goal
to get questions right.
I hope they don't
get them right
because
they should be hard.
After people
answer a question,
I actually have them all
talk to each other in groups.
Students come to class
and sit next to
the same people every day.
They will be talking
with those students,
trying to figure out
this stuff,
then they will have
the opportunity to learn
and to meet other people
as they're doing it.
This is very different
than the "sage on the stage,"
the approach that most
professors make at universities.
Is it rare
in computer science
that other professors
use this method?
Not so much anymore.
When I started doing it,
I was the first person
in the computer science
department here at UCSD
to adopt peer instruction
and one of the first
in the nation as well,
with the goal of trying
to increase retention
in our introductory
programming courses.
This became something
that people noticed.
I wrote publications on it,
and people saw
and came to my classroom
and saw how engaging it was.
Honestly, for a professor,
it's more fun to work with them
in answering their questions,
rather than repeating the same
things you've said before.
It wasn't hard to convince
faculty to do it.
I know that your teaching
and emphasis on teaching
this kind of learning,
it goes outside the university.
You also have a passion for
helping high school students.
We're involved in a grant
with funding from NSF.
We now are training high school
teachers in San Diego,
in three districts: Sweetwater,
San Diego Unified, and Vista.
You've had a profound effect
on a teacher in particular,
Art Lopez, a high school teacher
at Sweetwater District.
Can you talk about him
and how he has embraced
your computer science
principles class?
It's almost
impossible to explain
how much we at the university
need colleagues like Art Lopez.
We really can't make
the impact that we need
without these dedicated teachers
in the local communities
because they're on the ground
and what makes things work.
I got to know Art
when I first developed
one of the first five
national university pilots
of a new
advanced placement course
that we were developing
in computer science
called CS Principles.
I knew that I had
to develop this course
that would serve
a broad range of students,
students with varying
backgrounds in computing,
perhaps even computer-phobic
starting off.
With that in mind,
I developed this course
based around peer instruction
and getting students to think
about how computers work
and believe they
had control over them.
We were able to recruit a group
of teachers in San Diego.
Art Lopez was
one of the first ones.
Now, Art was a standout
from the beginning.
We had an eight-week
training course.
He found out that I was
teaching Tuesday and Thursday
and said,
"Can I come to your class?"
Almost every class
for that quarter,
Art attended my lectures
and sat there
and behaved as a student,
experienced a classroom
as a student
and loved the engagement
that he saw,
loved the concepts
that students were learning.
He took this back
to his classroom,
and instead of doing what
most courses do in high school
and is considered the norm,
where kids work
on their computers,
and you stand behind them
and help,
he adopted this
flipped classroom model,
where he would have
the students do--
We created an online textbook
for students.
He worked with them
through that
and ran these
peer instruction questions
with his students
having clickers.
Now in his classroom,
students aren't
silently sitting there,
staring at a computer,
typing.
They are talking.
They're gathering
around each other,
arguing about something.
The thing
will be on the screen,
they'll be pointing at it,
and he will listen in and
hears what people talk about.
Students learn that computing
isn't just about boring people
staring at computers.
You have to talk about code
because software
is developed in teams.
You need to be able
to communicate
and collaborate
with other people
in order to be successful
in the computing field.
It's helped the idea
of broadening participation
in computer science.
Art has a lot
of Latina students,
so he's brought in female
students into computer science
that are opening up a new area
of going to college
and majoring
in computer science.
You and I were back East
at a National Science Foundation
meeting earlier this year.
It was after President Obama's
last State of the Union address.
We should build
on that progress
by providing pre-K for all
and offering every student--
[applause]
...offering hands-on computer
science and math classes
that make them job-ready
on day one.
We should recruit and support
more great teachers
for our kids.
[applause]
And then he announced
his initiative,
Computer Science For All,
and he's seeking $4 billion
backing from Congress
to make sure that students--
every student in our nation--
has computer science courses
that they can take
and be at least literate.
What will this do
for our country,
this Computer Science For All
initiative?
It's absolutely imperative
that we get started on this.
It has the potential
to do amazing things.
Just think about it
this way.
We know the three R's:
reading, writing,
and arithmetic.
These are critical
to everyone's success.
Whether you're going to become
a university professor
or start your own business,
you need those skills
in order to accomplish
the basics in life,
to understand whether your
company is financially viable,
to market your company,
etcetera.
Well, really,
does anybody do anything
that doesn't really
involve computing anymore?
I can't wait to see
your office.
It's very small, but...
(Karen)
Not only does Beth teach
computer science in class,
she also reaches students
and teachers online
by producing videos
in her campus office
that is also her studio.
I have my laptop set up
and ready to record.
I just turn on my lights.
Lighting?
I have my microphone.
And I have
my green screen behind me,
and I'm recording
off my camera.
Lighting, camera, action.
This is the basic setup
I use to record.
I bring up my PowerPoint slides,
and I'm ready to go.
You recently took
a sabbatical at Coursera,
an education technology
company
that offers quite a few MOOCs,
Massive Open Online Courses.
What's the role
in online education,
particularly
in computer science?
Where's all this going?
It is an open question,
but to get to the fact
that we are going to need
many, many more high school
teachers teaching computing,
I think online
has an opportunity there.
So let's just set the stage.
People may be unaware.
Think about
your local high school.
How many math teachers
are there?
Every student is taking
a math course every year.
You expect a lot
of math teachers.
Your local high school
may have zero teachers
who are trained
to teach computing.
Zero teachers. Forget
trained to teach computing.
They may have zero teachers
teaching computing.
Here in the state of California,
up until very recently,
if you took a computing class,
it actually counted--
It didn't count toward
graduation requirements,
which means
it counts against it,
and their parents
wouldn't let them take it.
But the thing is we're really
starting from ground zero,
and I don't know
of another discipline
where an advanced,
massive educational system,
like the K-12 system
in the U.S.,
is bringing something all-new
for the first time
that would be required.
Another major problem
that we have
is that we believe that,
first off,
we don't have enough
computer science majors,
and although we don't actually
have evidence for this,
but we believe
it would be challenging
to convince those
computer science majors
to teach in schools,
like math majors choose
to teach math in schools,
because the pay is low,
compared to what they can
command working in industry.
But we do have are
very smart schoolteachers,
and we have very interested
teachers who,
given the opportunity with
their great experience already
at being teachers,
could get up to speed
more quickly
teaching computing content
if they just had access
to the disciplinary knowledge
that we can provide them,
as well as the shared knowledge
that we'll have to be developing
in how to teach computing
at various grade levels.
So I think online has
the potential for scaling out
and help building up these
communities of teachers--
maybe one in one school
and one in another school--
and make them
more of an online community
because we know online education
doesn't work very well
for what we would call
novice or beginner students.
You know, 10-year-olds,
14-year-olds, 18-year-olds,
there's evidence showing
that what we're doing now
in online learning
often isn't very successful,
especially
if we think of a MOOC.
That's because
students need motivation.
They need to have a real desire
for wanting to learn something
to be successful at a MOOC.
Well, teachers who are looking
forward to teaching a course,
they're pretty masterful
learners themselves,
and that might be a way to
give them access and opportunity
to develop the skills that they
need to teach these courses.
So what's next for you
in computer science education?
What do you see
on the horizon?
Right now
in the state of California,
we're in an amazing time
of opportunity.
Just April 1st of 2016,
they adopted a new,
what's called
supplemental credential
to actually credential teachers
to teach computing
in the schools in California.
There had been an old one,
but you can tell it was old
'cause it talked about things
like modems and dial-up.
So this is
a modern credential
with modern goals to it,
and there's currently
no existing curriculum
in universities in California
for teaching teachers
so that they can get accredited
in the supplemental credential.
So I'm looking forward
to working collaboratively
with friends
in the Cal State system
and in the UC system
to develop and begin offering
courses here at UCSD
and for teachers
here in San Diego.
Fantastic.
Thank you, Beth.
Thank you for your passion
for computer science education.
We look forward
to great things.
Great to talk to you.
Thanks.
Funding to purchase and make
this educational production
accessible was provided by the
U.S. Department of Education:
PH: 1-800-USA-LEARN (V)
or WEB: www.ed.gov.
♪